c'est par la voix du leader du groupe
djihadiste boko haram que l'enlèvement a
été revendiqué
je suis abubakar shekau et nos frères
sont derrière l'enlèvement de katsina
vendredi dernier ce sont plus de 330
élèves de l'école de garçons de kankara
qui ont été victimes d'un rapt organisé
une centaine d'assaillants ont fait
irruption à moto
une fusillade a éclaté avec les forces
de sécurité plusieurs centaines d'élèves
ont pris la fuite dans une forêt
environnante et une partie d'entre eux a
été enlevé le gouverneur de l'état
immédiatement réagi nous ferons tout ce
qui est en notre pouvoir pour retrouver
les enfants enlevés les familles des
lycées enlevé tente depuis plusieurs
jours de garder espoir
les parents de quelques élèves se
rendent chaque jour devant leur école
pour prier en attendant un possible
retour la tristesse reste quant à elle
très présente
je ne peux pas mesuré ma colère c'est le
quatrième jour que l'on vient le matin
devant cette école et nous restons
jusqu'à 18 heures aucune femme ne veut
être dehors à cette heure là mais nous
ne pouvons pas dormir nous ne pouvons
pas manger nos enfants nous manque trop
quand nous voyons les agents de sécurité
cela nous redonne l'espoir de revoir nos
enfants enfin ne représente pas une
seule mère ya plusieurs centaines
d'enfants ont été kidnappés je les
considère tous comme mes enfants à north
one
je ne pleure pas seulement pour mon
enfant mais pour tous ceux qui ont
disparu jazz la passerelle chaumont un
événement qui a fait enfler les
critiques contre le président mamadou
buhari qui se trouvait à 200 kilomètres
des lieux dans son fief
si le chef d'état a condamné l' attaque
la qualifiant de mener par des lâches
envers des innocents il ne s'est pas
pour autant rendu sur les lieux du drame
face à cette inaction le parti
démocratique populaire a demandé
l'ouverture d'une procédure de
destitution à son encontre